so uh thanks everyone for joining and
welcome to this talk about uh unified
patch and stream processing in Python um
a quick uh summary of what we GNA talk
about or really the only thing you
should remember when you leave The Talk
is that uh with the right tooling you
can reuse your batch code in your stream
jobs um so a quick outline of what we're
going to talk about we're going to start
with an example where we're going to
write a bad job and in this bad job
we'll calculate features for a machine
learning model probably something you
guys do every day uh and then we'll move
on to reimplementing this job so it can
serve the features in real time so we'll
go from a bad job to stream job and
while doing that we'll realize that it's
a lot of work and it'll be much easier
um if we could reuse the batch code
instead of having to reimplement it uh
and we'll see that to do that we need
two things we'll need a better
representation of the data using apach
Aro and a framework to orchestrate the
execution with
beavers so a little bit about me uh my
name is Arthur Andes I'm a software
engineer at Treadwell Technologies uh
you can find me on GitHub as0 x26
RS so um as promise we'll start with an
example so at trade well we help our
client buy and sell corporate bonds
corporate bonds are a financial product
that trade very sporadically and it's
very hard to know their prices and part
of our client offerring is a
state-of-the-art and industry-leading
corporate bond pricing model um and so
it's basically a machine learning model
and it has some very complicated
features or features come from various
data sources and those data sources have
got um heterogen genous uh data
structure as well as they come at very
different frequen frequency and we do a
lot of complicated temporal joints
between those different time series it
requires a lot of historical data but in
the meantime it also requires us to have
the latest data in order to make
accurate prediction so we actually When
developing a pressing model we spend
more time on the features preparation
than on the calibration of the inference
so let's look at a specific bone and
understand exactly what the problem is
so here we' got this bone
uh7 maybe you've heard of it it's quite
a popular bone actually and um there's a
lots of observations therefore it's easy
to predicts its next price um we move on
to the next
bone8 probably never heard of it it's
not as popular there's fewer
observations and it's very hard to
predict its next price um so we spend a
lot of time looking at the data
squinting very hard at it and we figured
like that those bone are correlated they
move together so what we would like to
do is use information from bone7 to
predict the price
of8 um so we start with observation so
time stamp a bond and a price and
observation is basically a trade that
happen in the market and from this Trad
we can get the price uh we get a
prediction request which is just a time
stamp and a bond and it means that we
would like to predict the price of this
Bond at this given time stamp and in
this example the features we want to
calculate are the previous price for
bond8 so what was the price of bond8 the
previous time it trades and also a
second feature is how much did 007
change since the last time bond8 has
traded so these are two features um
and um so visually it looks like that we
we go back in time to find the previous
trade for bon8 and we look at how much 7
has changed
um we start by doing a batch
implementation of this job uh so in this
example it looks like this we've got
observations in the CSV file prediction
request in a CSV file we load them we
feed them to a python function we get
the features we save them in a CSV file
um and really the key point to remember
here is that um we we want to calculate
some features we have a python function
that takes some data frames in uh and
spit out some data frames it does some
complicated stuff it doesn't really
matter what it does um and um in order
to do that it requires um some history
of its inputs in particular the
observation we need an history of it in
order to calculate relevant features um
and so we wrot this patch up we wrot
dispatch code it works great the boss is
very happy and he ask us like we need to
put this into production and we need to
generate those features in real
time so now we're moving to the stream
implementation um so let's talk a little
bit about the difference between badge
and stream jobs so in a badge job you
optimize for throughput um so you you
care about how much data you can process
c um you read the data typically in bulk
from for example a CSV file and because
of this you can leverage data analytics
Library like
pandas uh on the other end of stream job
you optimize for latency so you receive
a request and you want to reply as fast
as possible um you receive data one
record at the time so you could receive
your data from Kafka or rest API uh and
the data is represented like one record
at a time as a Jen dictionary
or like a plan python object which mean
you cannot really use pandas with this
data um so uh in this example we'll use
Kafka if you're not familiar with Kafka
I'll give you like a 30 second
introduction it's a distributed
streaming platform um it allow you to
allows you to broadcast messages between
services and one key feature of Kafka
that is very useful for us is that the
consumer of messages when they restart
they can replay historical data so in
our example we require history of the
observations in order to calculate
features which mean that when features
calculation job dies in the middle of
the day and we restarted we can replay
from Kafka the history of the
observations so then we've got all the
data we need to uh serve accurate
features without having to load them
from a file or from a database um
so our stream job looks like that so it
looks very similar from to our um bad
job except the data in stuff coming from
CSV file uh from from
cka um and if we go ahead and do like a
plan python implementation of the job uh
we start receiving observations so they
look like this they're like just one
record uh put in a dictionary and we
would like to store those observations
in the that
structure um that uh we can query
efficiently and the type of query you
want to do is first we want to find the
bond based on their bond ID so is it
bond7 is it bond8 so we'll first key the
data by um Bond ID and store it in a
hashmap which means we'll have very fast
look up of O of one and then the next
thing we want to do is look them look
them up based on the time stamp so for
this we'll use a sorted list and it
means we can look them up in or log n
um so we receive observation we put them
in this complicated data structure and
then when we receive a prediction
request it means we can very quickly
look up the information we need to put
together the
features but what happened here is that
in order to create this plan stream
implementation way to come up with this
complicated data structure way to write
a lot of code that is very imperative
and it's probably has got off bugs um
and now we've got two different version
of the code to maintain the stream
version and the patch version and like
every time we have to change something
we have to change it in both place and
make sure that they do the same thing uh
which is kind of a pain to maintain and
lastly like um plan python can be quite
slow and it can use a lot of memory so
um it doesn't sound great and we we come
to ask yourself would it be easier if we
could just reuse the code we had written
before uh to calculate all
features so the first step to do so is
to prepare the streaming data so we can
reuse or batch code so if you remember
the batch code was just this function
that was taking pandas data frame as
input and spitting out pandas data frame
as an output um so but at the moment
we're in this situation where we're
receiving Jon
[Music]
Jon record one by one and want to con
them to a pandas data frame um so uh it
wouldn't be a good idea to take one Jon
record and convert it to a data frame
because it's not very efficient like
data Frame Works much better if you have
a certain amount of Records in them so
instead of uh receiving data one by one
we're going to receive the data in we're
going to process the data in microb
batches so there's different strategies
in terms of how you define your micro
batches in your real-time job uh you can
batch your record by time so every 100
milliseconds you can batch your record
by um a record of the same size so for
example a thousand record uh you can
bdge by a mix of both but what we found
work best for us in terms of
reactivity uh is to flush all the
available message that in your Kafka
buffer uh because in Kafka when you
receive the message they are being
queued in the buffer and you can read
all of them so then you you'll use all
the available information um when you
process the
messages so that the first step we've
got to record in micro batches uh our
first batch of message comes in it looks
like this we've got from the
observations to pick we've got three
observations from the prediction request
we've got one uh request um we can
easily convert it to data frames using
the pandas Library um we can do the same
thing for the prediction
request and lastly we can call Patch
function um to calculate the features so
you may think oh it's great job done but
there's a few issues with this approach
uh when it comes using
pandas um so imagine there's a second
batch of record that comes in we've got
two observations and no prediction
request this
time then uh we convert the incoming
observation to a data frame and we need
to concatenate those incoming
observation to the existing uh
observations we happen to the table um
and if you're familiar with pendas uh
you learn that concat is a very slow
operation because he needs to copy the
data it's going to be a problem for us
because we're going to have a long
history of observations and at every
cycle we're going to app like a few rows
but it's going to require us to do a
very big
copy
the other issue with the pendas is that
it's not exactly type save so because we
didn't receive any prediction request I
can convert the prediction request to a
data frame but then I end up with this
empty data frame that's got no columns
and it's quite bad uh and you end up
with code like this where every time
you've got a data frame you have to
check if it's empty and if it's empty
you return an empty data frame if it's
not empty you can um do some processing
and this trickle done done stream in all
the code base and it starts spinning bad
very quickly so we don't really want
code like
this so to summarize what we talked
about here uh about pandas um there's
issue with concatenating it's slow and
it's not type safe so can we find
something better so we're in this
sitation we've got CSV we've got Jon
we've got pandas we want to go in
between if efficiently and um we're
going to introduce aacho as an
intermediate in memory representation
for the data to solve all those
problems so apach Aro is an IM memory
format for tabular data so think about
it as a bit like pandas but a bit more
low level and more focus in how the data
is represented rather than being focused
on how can I do like data
wrangling uh so let's give it a try
we'll install it and import it and we'll
see what it's like to convert the data
using Arrow so we go back to the
beginning I've got my first batch of
messages coming in and to convert the
data using Arrow uh One requirement is I
introduce a schema so for every uh table
I would have to specify the schema of
the of the table which is just the name
of the columns and the types so it might
feel like it's a lot of effort
especially if you used to the ease of P
Pon and not having to Define any type
but it's very valuable both in terms of
type safety and
documentation and then um I can convert
my recurse to a table using the
schema I do the same thing with the
prediction request I introduce the
schema I call the record I've got my
table and then I can call calculate
features by converting the arrow tables
to Panda's data frame and um one
advantage of Arrow is that those tables
to convert them to T frame is very fast
because it's a zero copy operation which
is creating a view of the
table uh and then the second batch of
messages come in I processed uh the
observations I convert them to a table
and I can then concatenate the
observation table with the new record
and
in uh in Arrow this is a very fast
operation because because it doesn't
require any
copy um we can do the same thing so with
the prediction request we convert them
and you notice that this time we've got
this empty um table but we still have
retained the schema of the table we
still know that there's a time stamp and
a bone which mean I can cut I can call
the uh my function without it
crashing um and we got rid of all the
old SM code that we had before we spend
that which is
great so to summarize with arrow U we've
got a type safe um environment we've got
fast zero copy fast sorry fast zero copy
concatenation of tables and also
converting to pandas is very fast and a
zero copy
operation so what we achieved here is a
unified data representation we're able
to represent the data in a batch uh jobs
in the same way that we're represented
in a stream job meaning meaning we can
use the same code the next step is to
orchestrate the data flow in a similar
way between the stream and the bad job
um and uh let me talk about the specific
challenges of orchestrating
orchestrating the data flow in a
streaming job so first uh we want to
manage the size of the batches that we
receive from Kafka so I'll talk about
the different strategies for microb
batching it's actually not that simple
to implement um especially if you want
to limit the size of your batches uh and
not have too much data into memory and
the other thing that we need to manage
is that we need to replay the messages
across different data sources in the
correct order and what I mean by that is
that uh in a specific example uh to
calculator features we need the history
of the
observations um and we cannot uh um we
cannot make prediction until we have
received all the relevant
observations uh and more specifically
like if you look at this patch of
messages for example you can see that
the observations are from the beginning
of the month of January when the
prediction request is from the end of
the month and this typically what
happens uh with cafka when you start
replaying messages because cafka is not
going to replay the message in order uh
when they come from different data
sources so from different uh topics
so these are key features that we would
want for framework when it comes to uh
Rand or stream
jobs so we've looked at existing
framework for streaming and uh we
actually didn't find one that was
suitable for or problem space um and so
this here the limitation we found with
the existing framework um the the key
aspect of it is that most of those
Frameworks are optimized for latency and
they tend to process one record at a
time so what they're trying to do is
deal with transactional workload but we
more focused on analytical P
workload um some of them are quite
heavyweight libraries so they're require
you to operate a cluster some of them
are running in Java uh some of them have
got intrusive API so you'll have to
rewrite your code in order to use the
framework uh some of them only support
linear workflow so you cannot do joints
between data sources uh which is kind of
a prime when you calculate features
because calculating features is 99%
joins and um lastly most of them don't
solve the problem that I just explained
about replaying data from different data
sources um in a timely fashion so that's
why uh at tradewell we came up with
beavers to solve all those problems and
in a nutshell beavers is a streaming
processing python Library
optimized for
analytics and it all all the problem
that I just mentioned with the other
Frameworks so let's talk a little bit
about how beavers work um so the first
thing you need to do with beavers is you
create a
dag so a DG is a directed acylic graph
and it's basically a way to orchestrate
your
computation uh in a streaming fashion um
so in your D you got three type of nodes
at the top you've got the sources um so
this is the input coming from the
outside world so where does the data
come from um in between you've got the
computational nodes and those
computational nodes are just python
function that have been wrapped and put
in the tag and lastly you've got the sys
so this is the outputs of the tag and
the edges so the connection between the
nodes they represent the input of the
Python function so they parameters or
the
arguments so we'll start by looking at
the API we have to build a dag so we
create a dag and first thing is we
create the source node so for for Source
node we just Define a name and a schema
the schema is optional but it allows you
to solve the problem we've seen before
where you've got a lot of empty data
frames bu no schema that creates a lot
of issues in your code um so here I
defined my obervation and my prediction
request
Source um I can then add computational
nodes one important not about comput nod
is that we have two types of nodes um
we've got uh stream nodes they compute
Emeral events and those events only
leave for one cycle during the next
cycle of update we forget about them so
the features for example we calculate
them and then at the next cycle we don't
really care about them can just replace
them with an empty value and then we've
got the state node and the state not a
persistant from cycle to cycle so for
example the observation history uh we
want to keep that from one cycle to the
next even though there were no new
observations coming in during that
cycle uh so this is a key feature that
we borrowed from cfq if you're familiar
with this
framework uh so here we're going to add
the observation history note so it's
just a note that when you receive new
observation you will openen them to a
table and keep accumula accumulating
and return this whole history so we add
it to the dag by putting the function in
the doag and then um connecting it to
the observation Source by calling the
map
function and then we can add the
features calculation to the tag so the
feature stream uh will be connected to
the observations history and the
prediction request source and an
important thing for stream note is that
we have to specify the empty value so if
they don't update we can replace um we
can replace the Mt value with something
meaningful so we again avoid this issue
with this mini code we we talked about
before and lastly we've got sync node so
for syn node we just um give them a name
and that's the
output and so we have a d here um and so
far we've only focused on putting the
business logic in the dog we haven't
said where does the data come from and
so that's what we're going to talk about
now so there's essentially three ways to
provide the data and execute the dog one
way is to do it manually so you will set
the inputs of each node yourself execute
the dag and look at the output that's
good for you test but it's very labor
intensive the second way is to do it in
live mode with
CFA and the Third Way is to do it in
replay mode with files so we only going
to really talk about the live mode here
because we have that much time um so uh
we have our dag we want to specify where
do the data come from so um for each
Source in the dag we'll specify the name
of the topic in kfka how the data is
deserialized so in our example we've
been using Jon but you may want to use
Proto or Arro it's up to you really we
don't um have any opinion on how the
data should be represented and lastly
the offset policy so the offset policy
basically says like after far in the
past you want to replace the data so in
our example we want to replay the whole
hisory of the observations that's
available in kfka but for prediction
request we only care about the latest
one uh then we do the same thing for
things we specify the name of the topic
and how it's being um
serialized um and that's it we can just
run it and we've got our live job
running and calculating features in real
time um
so it looks a little bit like this so
all we did is um we took a dag and we
just connected the input and the output
to some
catop um and I'll briefly talk about the
replay mode uh the replay mode is it
allows you to um run your dag with data
that stored in files or in the database
and it's good if you want to test your
dag with historical production data or
if you want to backfill some data so you
change some parameters and you want to
backfill the hisory and it's also very
useful for profiling if you find that
your dog in real time is a bit slow and
you want to figure out where does the
slowness come from and essentially what
you would do is you just specify where
again where does the data come from and
where does the data go so instead of
specifying cat topic you just specify
files CSV par or whatever you want to
use and with with this we've achieved
like unified data
orchestration uh which mean we can use
or stream job and or bad job in a
similar way we've got one doag and we
can run it in both um mode so in
conclusion like uh what I would say is
like you can unify batch and streaming
with apach r beavers you'll only have if
you do so you'll only have to implement
your job wants um and you'll save memory
and you'll increase throughput uh by
using um this uh this approach so uh
thanks for your time if you get a chance
uh please give it a start on GitHub and
uh you can play around with it by just
installing it with Pip all right thank
you very
much hi Arthur thank you so much for
that talk that was great um we have a
few minutes left that we can take any
some questions uh I guess we do have one
going up there are a couple coming in uh
first yes yeah you see that okay sure
there you go yeah sure so uh yeah that's
a good question so um I could provide
the resources yes uh let me find them
because it's briefly mentioned in all
documentation uh so I will post the
[Music]
link uh
up
so I'll post a link in the Q&A in the
chat sorry to answer this question if
you go in this section of the doc the
top uh is um the top explains like how
you can
manually uh unit test your tag and it
shows that it's quite labor intensive
and there's better ways to do it but um
it's still a useful
feature okay we got another question
yeah so yes p is implemented in Python
indeed um and I know that there are some
other similar Frameworks implemented in
um in Russ for example but what we find
is that
actually um like you may say oh python
is a bit slow why would you use Python
to do that but beers doesn't do a lot of
work actually beers just orchestrate the
data flow the duty is done by the
function that are being called by divers
and typically um those function should
call like cod like um apach Aro or
pandas which will then call like native
code return in
C++ or
um um or C or rust so you're essentially
just orchestrating some heavy duty task
that are written in
Python
yeah
I think you have one more there
Arthur uh can you um I guess not really
so um you I mean you can do anything you
want essentially the node in the python
dog a python function so then you could
call uh some stuff done in DBT or maybe
a duck DB for example if you're using
SQL
um but it's not SQL Focus we mainly
focus in orchestrating tasks that have
been return in pandas polas or Arrow